pour les censurer c'est donc fixé l'aft
c'est vrai on peut plus rien dire moi je
pensais que ce public c'est l'heure pour
aider un truc parce que personne ne
regarde pas même sur public sénat
on ne peut rien dire quoi mal ça va très
mal ça va mal enfin il ya une pandémie
on n'est pas au courant public sénat ou
quoi là la relance économique se
relancent pas du tout là s'est lancé
lancé l'an est ce que les gens vont re
consommer on a besoin de savoir ça on
est dans l' angoisse là non ça va pas
faut consommer les gens c'est un cahier
de vacances avec deux véritables
exercices qui sont inspirés d'actualité
et de personnages d'actualité c'est à
dire que y'a de la rigolade
mais ce sont des vrais exercice avec les
corrigés à la fin le but c'est de gagner
des points retraite et de donner des
sous à la fondation abbé pierre
tout à fait et tout ça en faisant quoi
des vacances apprenant des vacances
apprenants de continuité pédagogique
tout à fait pour faire plaisir à qui a
manu monsieur le président et ami jean
michel blanquer gens mais qui a fallu
qu'il ya son autocollant parce que dans
le cahier de manu il ya des autocollants
oui et alors on peut on y voir vous
montrez l'année dernière il y avait un
manu a découpé puis on a mieux cette
année on a un petit carlos a découpé
pour le mettre dans sa valise et
l'emporter partout en voyage parce qu'il
aime bien voyager carlos s'il aime bien
je pense qu'on peut vraiment oui là il
faut vraiment un hors série il faut y
consacrer au même plusieurs volumes sur
sur dix est très très passionnée 1 cm et
moi je suis très très passionnée de
désir à l'aliénation là quand même je
connais tous avec des petits melon à
découper parce que si emmanuel macron
ils nous appellent et là il a appelé
billard bêtement pour la réouverture des
bars ils nous appellent c'est pour le
aller le conseiller à l'élysée moi je
dis oui et on prendra montant pas moins
de sept cas sont fausses et eddy stan et
pourvu qu'on refasse pas la vidéo avec
public sénat ce qui m angoisse
sa fille moi je voulais moi je voulais
pas me fâcher que bruno retailleau
oui parce que c'est notre cas sûr de la
droite donc
bon ben ah ouais bruno ces mondes à
bruno kwast ouais c'est vrai qu'il nous
manque un peu bruno vivien mois là j'ai
rares l'archi il est des nôtres
j'ai cité champions hachette cahiers de
vacances avec ton pognon
[Musique]
aubin besoins non je pense non pas le
coran navires us le traitement de
gestion de la crise
les masques en tension on va suivre ça
de près c'est cet été là c'est bientôt
la fin juin ok on sera là on sera là
devant un public sénat d'une façon
collectionneurs c'est la chaîne qu'on
regarde le plus un bien sûr tout public
c'est là toutes les émissions
le matin la matinale de public sénat
j'aime bien public sénat la nuit - oui
la nuit il ya des trucs un peu la nuit
on sait pas pour l'instant tout cas
l'avenir est fait on sait déjà pas de
quoi est fait l'avenir du monde d'après
tu voudrais pas qu'on sache ce qu'on
fait l'année prochaine c'est angoissant
c'est parce que c'est une chaîne tourné
vers l'avenir alors tout de suite il
nous parle du 3 dont on vient de sortir
le deuil nous parle du 3 il ya une
ardeur d'avancé public sénat j'ai
l'impression qu'à glisser la
dessinatrice
c'est le plus beau c'est ouais elle
vient de bordeaux
kyl sénateur dans la région
ben voilà c'est pas ça ça va lui coûter
son poste à pas seulement un truc pareil
je vais manger n'est hélas calibre isole
et et et grisolles par rapport au sénat
qu'est-ce qui est sorti à ce dernier une
commission denquête encore ah oui
[Musique]